slowly  some small gates  yeah i mean bishop h3o book c1 or  something here must be there must be a  way  but i'm pretty sure that here he he was  not happy with his position he felt that  it's uncomfortable to play  yeah i asked the computer yeah minus  zero thirty five minus zero fifteen oh  no it's already  ready and the game is over  he didn't wait for h5 here like he  waited for fabi to come  back incredible round guys  yeah and how did we do in the prediction  front we  got a couple of decisive games today ooh  it was nice  four draws for draw strategy didn't work  out  and with you she always predicts a  rapport win but rapper always draws so  we can count that as a correct